gameplay pulled up for us here we are
starting out James there there you are
you're wearing the house fanatic robes
uh from the from the account linking
thank you thank you yeah I do look good
and this is our first look at the
Hufflepuff common room I'm assume I mean
dorm room dorm room yeah yeah this is
awesome but Alan what are we seeing
right here with the UI because this is
our first look
yeah so um right now we know there's
been a lot of questions about uh
about about the HUD because this is the
first time we're showing it so um kind
of going over from right to left on the
bottom right is what we call Our Spell
Diamond so those are everything that you
see in it are slottable spells so we
have over 20 slatable spells that you
can earn over the course of the game
okay and and that's where the player can
place them and use them and access them
very quickly
um to the top left of that is you'll see
the d-pad and on the left is an eyeball
and on the right is a bit of a grid so
uh the eyeball is an example of one of
not a slottable spell but what we call
an essential spell there are certain
spells that are used in very specific
contexts or or that we just want on the
controller at all times and revello is
one of those that's left on the d-pad on
the right on the d-pad is that grid
represents where you might slot spells
and so okay right now today we're not
going to be going into the spell
slotting menu because we feel like
there's a lot of spoilers there you know
like what are all the Spells and what
can we do but
we do want to make sure there's still
some goodies left to share with everyone
and then on the left side that thing
that has the one button next to it
that's another thing where we don't want
to spoil but basically that's where you
access your tool wheel so there's a lot
of magical tools that you're going to be
uh kind of brewing and growing over the
course of the game and so that's where
you would access them rapidly is our two
wheel okay cool um there are a few
things that I left off the table on the
right the green bar is your health and
basically there's a potion next to it
that's how you might heal the bar above
it we're keeping a secret for now I
apologize and uh all the way on the left
is our mini-map with a kind of overhead
view of where you are currently in your
common room that updates as you travel
through Hogwarts and Beyond out into the
world and for those those fans out there
that aren't a huge fan of Minnie Mouse
because we know they exist there's also
options to remove the mini-map and turn
on or off different elements of our HUD
if you immerse yourself yeah and yeah
and we'll go more into the Spells as we
get into combat but that's kind of
that's that's what you're seeing there
and this is our HUD also Andrew's giving
us a good look over here I want to I
want to call out uh I'm a big fan of the
bedside tables in the dormitories
um
very nice bedside tables they are nice
bedside tables yeah the honey colored
wood was mentioned in the writing it's
part of Laura it's part of Lord there we
go all right so now we're walking out
into
we we really tried making these low
ceiling dorms to give you that Badgers
yeah sort of feel the first thing I know
is the music the score is amazing with
this gorgeous and I'm calling out here
uh this is unique music that you're
hearing for the Hufflepuff common room
go back to those common Room videos we
released you'll notice the music's a
little bit different and that is
entirely intentional
we just want to welcome you to your
common room in every single house just a
little bit differently so you can
customizing that experience right away
oh my gosh it's so awesome look at that
so I mean beautiful design I I we could
spend like the entire rest of the stream
just in the common room here and talking
about it and I'm sure Boston and James
could be like just geeking out over here
this all the details come from JK
Rowling's writings for this common room
the round doors the hanging Vines even
the dancing Badgers on the tires yeah
it's very very earthy which is which is
like elements for each of the houses
right like this earth ravenclaws air
gryffindor's fire and Slytherin is water
we really really leaned into that for
each common room wow so it feels earthy
we've got a little Earth and passageway
that's that's what we were hopefully it
should feel very familiar yeah yeah it
does it does but I I know you don't want
to leave but we're going to be leaving
thank you I understand
whoa the sound effects though like
looking back at the past trailers it was
just music but kind of hearing how
Hogwarts is now it's so cool it's
tactile yeah Andrew's gonna make use of
one of our spells for velio use rebellio
right here because there's a little
magic going on
so
um these are something that we kind of
interchangeably call revelo Pages or
lore pages and you'll notice a bunch of
things pop up on the screen yeah you see
that we got some XP for it and you can
also see that we've Advanced something
called like a field guide challenge so I
want to talk about that a little bit so
we had to ask ourselves what
I'm sorry there may be something you may
or may not be able to tickle that yeah
but uh in our game we had to answer the
question you know we're a late fifth
year what does that mean how do we catch
up to the other students okay okay so we
have an answer to that question and and
it's given to you by the staff so
there's something that we call the
Wizards Field Guide that's granted to
you early on in the game and the Wizards
Field Guide is how how you actually work
on catching up with the other students
so Andrew if you hit pause for me up
here before you push forward a little
bit you can see in our pause menu It's
Got This Book theme wow that's your
Wizards Field Guide and you can see your
house kind of crazy okay
you can see that on your level as well
so that the field guide has this magical
property of looking out into the world
around you and the reason why it's on
loan from the ministry of magic and the
professors have granted it to you as a
late fifth year student is because they
want it to help you catch up to the
other kids and its magical property is
to discover different opportunities to
learn and grow all around you so the way
it works is as you discover gameplay in
the game it actually recognizes that as
a challenge which is kind of locked into
there and Andrew if you go in there
you'll see different types of challenges
that are combat challenges Quest
challenges exploration challenges and
you can see Field Guide pages are on
there as well yeah
that one feel bad page that entire
category is one of the ways that the
book itself kind of fills out into the
school and Spills out into the school
and kind of hides itself with different
types of challenges and different things
to do around the school that you're
actually going to interact with to help
you grow as a wizard and practice your
spells and so that thing that we just
saw is not just a field guide Challenge
and a way to earn XP it's also something
that that players can use to learn about
the school as they're traveling around
they spot these little secret facts and
they can kind of play a little bit of a
game discovering all of them and their
their over 100 Field Guide Pages just in
Hogwarts alone a little glimpse of the
grand staircase here
circular circuits all the portraits and
I did notice the flu flame just ignite
right there which was so cool yeah oh
man fast travel points there house
hourglasses we had to I how much fun was
it designing those and putting all those
gorgeous but but they're just like in
the books yeah right to the Great Hall
is the non-to-lord house points is not a
core mechanic or system in the game it
is we narrowed it into like a gameplay
system but it's definitely present
throughout our narrative and and there
are lots of choices where we want to nod
to things that aren't aren't necessarily
gameplay systems but yeah but we nod to
them as as part of the narrative over to
the right
Andrew was teasing that's the Great Hall
over through those doors again we're not
going there where he's just kind of like
cool cool
uh here's another collectible page you
know just again showing you like just
these things around Hogwarts that you
can do and pick up and
that's a shot straight from the trailer
too it's that part right there I I
recognize that might be giving you a
little fan service here with uh with
callbacks to those so and this must be
summer time because I noticed these are
the summertime Windows these windows
will change with the seasons yeah the
detailing point of this is kind of it I
get surprised by it all the time
oh man
and we're going out
look at that this is where the students
would normally kind of congregate just
to kind of chill out play meet each
other outside the Great Hall before and
after meals
and I I love the way that when the
castle interconnects to uh that it
interconnects outside inside their their
pathways on both sides of things so you
really get a sense of scope to how big
this Castle is when you see things like
you you'll notice a bridge over there
that's a place you can go to and cross
like everything is everything that you
see is a place that you can visit wow we
tried so we put a lot of effort and make
it feel really alive not just with
student population but even just the
greenery and stuff it's Scotland yeah
and this Castle has been here for
hundreds of years so just kind of the
Moss and all the trees that have
overgrown it and oh my gosh that
landscape that Scottish might look a
little familiar to you um I thought I
recognized it I believe this is from the
spring ASMR and yes so that puzzle right
there that view uh Andrew is taking us
right back I'm going to tell Andrew not
to interact with that puzzle and to keep
moving on
no we can't spoil everything we can't
give you everything right Hogwarts
contains a lot of Secrets
but this is this Grand entryway right
here coming down into uh really kind of
Central Area yeah we're coming upon the
central Hall and we pointed out the
green house outside and and we'll notice
when we get down there that it's on the
right
this is a big Hub of the school like
it's a big castle but
um it is designed so you shouldn't get
very lost this is kind of a Grand
Central Station I love that each
Direction you know it's green over there
so the greenhouse is over there
Transfiguration Courtyard you know the
library straight ahead so it's kind of a
The Hub oh my God a lot of the castle
even the color visually you could just
tell okay green green
oh my God I should a lot of it will be
subconscious but it'll help you really
feel learn the castle and feel like you
know your way around
that's that's not to say that it's easy
to learn all of us here still get pretty
lost in it daily basis it's a castle
it's a great point
I love that Andrews uh definitely
teasing a lot of things here I'm
noticing he's swinging the camera this
way and that is
yeah he's got this grown on his face
over there that's just like yeah
that Dragon oh my God this is another
location where the students will gather
um you know and just kind of chill out
and an opportunity to uh talk to
somebody get a get a quest Giver here
is everything all right yes I'm sorry
I'm just I'm Nelly by the way I'm just
so excited that the daily and keys are
back the what keys the dedalian keys
surely you've seen them flying about
rumor is that a former headmistress
Professor mole conjured them to protect
the contents of certain locked cabinets
years ago Professor black couldn't be
bothered to disenchant the Keys and they
appear every few years you should try to
catch one
why would I do that each key will lead
you to a locked cabinet somewhere in the
castle if you can manage to get the key
into the cabinet lock not an easy task
you may find a reward
perhaps I'll give it a go I hope you do
in fact I think I heard one of the keys
in the astronomy Tower you should listen
for them
this is kind of side quests are really
it's a cool way to interact with your
fellow students with perhaps other
teachers with you know various things
like that as well as teach you some more
the secrets of Hogwarts I think there's
there's in this case absolutely yeah so
the students are a way to kind of like
flesh out the school opportunities
around it what what we can do and then
those interactions uh different
interactions with different characters
can also offer different Choice points
for the player and then some of those
things can can affect things game wide
some of these affect characters lives uh
the ending of the game
um and sometimes it's just about you
being a little bit just being a jerk
absolutely so the scale really varies
but but uh but those opportunities exist
for the player wow look at this
this is the Dada defense against the
dark arts the power power which this is
one of my favorite locations in
in the castle just visually you come in
here and just the the richness of this
area very unique to
anywhere else in the castle somebody
else that we can talk to uh notably a
younger student yeah she looks like a
first year or an 11 year old
are you all right don't you know who I
am
zenobian Oak the girl whom everyone at
school hates for no reason
everyone hates you
why because Hogwarts is full of bullies
and spoil Sports Leander Pruitt's one of
the worst that no Talent Moon mind I
wanted to make some new friends and so I
bought my collection down to the common
room my gobstone collection that is
I was hoping someone would want to play
are you familiar with gobstones little
balls like marbles Grand game and if you
lose they spray you with a foul-smelling
liquid
foreign
I haven't much interest in a game that
sprays you with odors only if you lose
which I never do or at least not often
people can be so cruel
just because they're sprayed all over
with smelly gobstones spit it's their
own fault for losing Imelda is one of
the worst losers ever written a story or
a terrible as well and now those poor
losers have taken my gobstones and
hidden them in very high places all over
the school
foreign
situation and they responded accordingly
I didn't make the
make them anyway
I can't work out how to get them back on
my own I don't think I know the
necessary spells yet
I need someone perhaps a selfless and
talented fifth year to help me
I'll see what I can do I don't
I did myself in no time
I love that interaction with her because
there's so many ways that you can go
with that you can like you can feel for
her you can be a jerk to her you can be
like a cop sound sounds awful it sounds
like you're just mean like oh yeah and
your opportunities to be mean there
aren't over yeah so they continue that's
a good example of the god gub Stones too
I know people are going to ask gobstones
of the gobstones playable they mentioned
it right yeah um so yeah golf sales is
one of the things that is not playable
in the game
um I know we've we've had to rip the
Band-Aid off on a few things I honestly
it's both in a it's an amazing thing on
the franchise how many things about this
like like speak to us as fans and that
we want to turn into gameplay and and
there were calls that we had to make
over the course of production of kind of
like which things we will and won't
include in the books just kind of for
the overall Wizards chess those are
things that aren't featured aren't
featured they're featured within the
world I'm glad they're mentioned they're
a part of the Wizarding World yeah every
single time there's something that we we
regretted because we couldn't include it
we also tried to figure out a way to
make sure it was included in the
narrative included in the stories make
sure that there's a way to kind of like
acknowledge it touch it you know and
make it feel like it's definitely part
of the world
and I know here too
I was like we're in this music is the
dark arts class I recognize that
staircase to the left where we were just
at Andrews walking by I also recognized
the dragon at the very top oh my gosh
being in a classroom I think this is a
good opportunity to talk about how
classes work because we've gotten a lot
of questions about that is it a schedule
based system is it to tell us how
classes work yeah so um ultimately you
decide not to go the Sim route so I
think like one of the speculations was
is there time of day and you know that
kind of thing like can I miss class at
this time of day there is a day night
cycle yeah yeah there is a day night
cycle but uh but everything is very um
narrative based and so there's a big
mystery going on in the world there's
something happening in the narrative and
we and we essentially see it as kind of
like chapters in that narrative each
chapter of which has a set of missions
that you can choose between as you're
progressing through the game and classes
fit within that structure so there are
Mainline things the players have to do
and then and classes also appear on the
sides as well as optional things that
help you advance your spells it's
absolutely true that classes provide all
of your major tools throughout the
gameplay your spells your major
abilities you get to know the professors
each one of them has these bespoke kind
of events yeah moments and those
missions and then there are also
additional opportunities outside of that
through kind of like side classroom
missions essentially where you can learn
additional spells or things that you
need in your adventure and also get to
know the professors better and I just
want to call out something that Andrew's
been kind of showing off ways to kind of
interact with the environment and just
just engage with the world and you know
maybe down there who's sipping some tea
Victorian Heist you know yeah High
Society I just no wonder you like this
area because we built it for like the
pure Bloods or the slytherins
well like speaking of lived in like the
sound effects again the chatter of the
communication that's happening and the
footsteps like it just makes it feel
more alive little events like that
I love that
the data Tower was one example but um no
two hallways should look the same in
Hogwarts it's a
it has a lot of Personality every
hallway should be a little bit different
and that's mostly to help Orient the
players right right help you not get
lost but uh this is Hesperus Hall that's
a little nod from the Marauders a name
that came from the Marauders map but
every hallway will have a little bit of
a different personality and
personality I like that because it gives
it does like Hogwarts has character
Hogwarts is its own character no matter
where you go
feels just a little bit different yeah
sentient Castle full of magic for
hundreds of years it's going to kind of
grow and develop oh I heard something
yeah speaking of characters speaking of
magic Mr Magic himself
you know we talked about building on
lore too another set statue over to the
side that's you know who that is Lachlan
the lanky and he's got his bowtruckle
friend and and I think if players don't
know there's another page there yeah
there's a map of argyle sure we know the
fat lady hides there hides behind it
that's right third butt but sometimes a
hallway has personality by how it looks
or we just passed a music hallway where
the portraits have kind of taken it over
and
um so the sound makes it really unique
all right I gotta call this out here I
know there's been some criticism in the
past that uh our trailer is our game
plan what we've shown so far has not had
enough owls okay so here we are at the
allery we're looking directly at the
allery to show you all of the owls
everything else it's a lot of hours I
love the fog rolling down now great
callback great call no I also I also
love that as I I one of my favorite
things about just kind of going around
on the outside of the school is that all
those things that I see are places that
I can go to that I can visit I just love
that sensation knowing that that is real
that lovely Scottish Countryside we're
kind of closing out our our mini tour of
Hogwarts and again but a fraction of uh
this enormous Castle
we're closing it out here in the Clock
Tower so I'm